paul thompson merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur air france alors on le
disait londres a fait savoir que les
progrès restent limitées dans les
négociations avec l'union européenne
pour michel barnier a rien de neuf
le royaume-uni at-il réellement l'envié
de jouer le jeu des négociations selon
vous bien sûr que oui c'est une
excitation qui a qui oppose deux
positions très différentes et il y à des
sujets majeurs qui sont qui sont qui
sont difficiles à résoudre le l'union
européenne estime que malgré le fait que
le royaume uni ne fait plus partie de
l'union européenne à l'oral unis devrait
néanmoins simplement garder les règles
de l'union européenne pour soi disant
pour assurer un avenir des conditions de
concurrence ait été réalisé jusqu'à même
paul thompson qu'est ce qui coince
toujours finalement dans ces
négociations
mais c'est le principe même principe la
souveraineté britannique
tout le sens du prêt qui consistait à
pouvoir reprendre le contrôle pour
utiliser le slogan qui a eu beaucoup de
succès pendant la campagne et à l'union
européenne en fait a beaucoup de mal à
admettre ce principe même aujourd'hui
alors que laurent emery est désormais
déjà sortir il y à des questions
concrètes comme la pêche là ce sont des
intérêts économiques qui qui qui se
posent et c'est une bagarre de gros sous
qui dans laquelle la france est
particulièrement impliqué mais il ya
d'autres pays qui est de l'union
européenne qui voudrait continuer à
avoir un accès à large au zoo du royaume
uni
et tout simplement de rahmouni être prêt
pour une négociation annuelle aux gets
l'idée d'une sorte de partage pérenne
voilà il faut savoir que dans une
négociation sur le sujet très complexe à
eva comme comme celui ci il est normal
que les négociations soient durs qu'il y
ait beaucoup de posture qu'ils soient et
de formules rhétoriques souvent assez
creuse en réalité à qui ce qui entre en
jeu
ça fait partie du parti du dudu de la
bêta de négociations kasic d'ailleurs
michel barnier lui même a dit
aujourd'hui que dans ce type de
négociations ni concession tout se
décide dans la dernière ligne droite et
il prédit que ce soit le cas ici
également et il a peut-être
il a peut être raison donc ils vont pas
thierry troqué épaules comme c'est
justement cette dernière ligne droite
est ce que ça pourrait être le conseil
européen prévu le 18 et 19 juin
prochains à ce qu' il pourrait être un
moment propice à ces avancées
c'est une excellente question
michel barnier a évoqué plus tôt
mais c'est vrai que le votre question
d'une grande pertinence parce que le
royaume uni avait dit qu'il était
important d'avoir arrêté au moins les
grandes lignes d'un accord pour fin juin
il me semble que ça va être très
difficile mais il faut espérer que à
l'occasion de ce sommet des progrès
significatifs soient réalisés ce serait
je ne crois pas moi même qu' il n'y aura
pas d'accord je pense que les les
intérêts en jeu sont des noms des deux
côtés et chaque côté à un intérêt
primordial à ce que mon avis à un accord
dès cosy
si on donne aux pme sont
particulièrement maximaliste je devais
l'idée que me dit de continuer emploi
table quelles règles européennes ayant
étant sorti contre tout bon sens et nous
nous ne faisons pas du tout la situation
dans les accords entre l'union
européenne et le canada où avoue le
japon donc cette même absurde comme
notre position mais il
il y a il faudra que les deux parties se
raccrocher et se met d'accord peut-être
que à ce sommet quelques grandes lignes
sera défini je ne suis pas trop
optimiste là dessus mais c'est sûr que
ce serait hautement souhaitable
merci beaucoup paul thompson d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique à paris